To show you how we can encode a single single snap shot on the REM
as a Boolean formula,
I'm going to show you a little trick with the Boolean formula.
So this Boolean formula--
it looks a bit intimidating, and it doesn't look fun.
Well I'll just quickly explain it to you and then help you figure out
the special property that it has.
So the formula consists of 6 variables:
X1, X2, X3 to X6
and it has 7 brackets,
so as you can see, each of those brackets contains
all of the 6 variables: X1, X2, X3, X4, X5, X6.
Sometimes they're a bit mixed up,
but every bracket here contains the 6 variables exactly once.
They're all connected with an and here,
and each one of them looks like this,
so up here you have an or over all of those variables,
and down here,
each bracket has a very similar structure,
so you have X1
or you have one of the variables
and a not of that variable,
or,
and this is a very big not
over off the other variables,
and those are combined by or.
Now probably it's a bit tough to figure out by yourself
what the purpose of this formula is.
I want you to figure it out,
but I will give you a few choices.
So what's special about this Boolean formula?
Does it not have any satisfying assignment?
Does it have several satisfying assignments?
Can it only be satisfied if exactly
one of those 6 variables is set to true,
and finally, if you generalize this,
so not 6 variables but any number n of variables,
and then you do the same structure as you do here.
That's the whole resulting formula,
have size 0 (n squared) for n variables?
So I think by now you're used to more than one of these answers
can be true, so check all of these that are correct.